اوهايو هذه الكلمه تقال دائما بدايه عندي
فضفضه صغيره قبل ست سنوات تقريبا هي كانت
اخر مره كنت على هذا الستيج نفتتح فعاليه
تدكس الرياض لاول نسخه لها واليوم انا
سعيد اكون احد المشاركين فما اقدر اعبر عن
كميه سعادتي اني اشوف الفعاليه هذه تستمر
سنه ورا سنه وبهذا الحضور الرائع وبنفس
الطاقه وكان افضل بعد فبغى تحيه قويه جدا
للفريق المنظم ولجميع الداعمين ولكم انتم
بعد اللي تدعمون هذه الفعاليات الله
عافي انا اليوم في يومي الثالث من عقدي
الثالث
حسب توقيت الزمني المتعارف فيه في الكره
الارضيه هنا او بدون فلسفه يعني صار عمري
سنه لما افكر دائما بالاسئله هذه او في
يوم الميلاد تحديدا واتوق اقع كثير منكم
تجيه تساؤلات هذه في يوم ميلاد انه انا ش
سويت ش انجازاتي ش الطموحات اللي جاي لها
وين مسار حياتي هل انا راضي عن حياتي الان
ولا لا تبدا تجي اسئله كثيره خصوصا بعد ما
تنهي مرحله معينه من حياتك وتنتقل لمرحله
جديده انتهيت من دراستي الان ومقبل على
فصل جديد من حياتي فتبدا تجي الاسئله متى
تتزوج متى تبني اسرتك وبيتك متى تشتغل او
ش الوظيفه اوش المسار الوظيفي اللي راح
تسلكه هذه كلها اسئله جدا مهمه وكل واحد
فينا يمر فيها في اوقات مختلفه من
حياته لكن انا بشارك معكم او افضفض معكم
انه مو هذا اكبر هاجس الان لانه هذه
الاشياء كلها او كلنا نقع تحت الضغوط من
المجتمع وخصوصا كنا في مجتمع متكاتف اننا
نجد اجابات لها خوفي الكبير وهاجس دائما
هو اني افقد شيء معين هذا الخوف ان نفقد
شيء كلنا نملك له وكلنا نولد بكميات كبيره
جدا منه وسنه ورا سنه احنا نفقد هذا الشيء
على شوي
شوي اعتقد بعضكم عنده الان فضول يبغى يعرف
شش هو هذا الشيء اذا كان عندك هذا الفضول
فهذه علامه جيده او ممكن لان لسه عمرك
صغير وما بعد فقدت الشيء هذا نعم انا
اتكلم عن الفضول الفطري الفضول اللي خلانا
نستكشف العالم من حولنا هذا الفضول اللي
يخليك تبغى تسافر الى بلد بعيده ولا تتعلم
لغه جديده هذا الفضول اللي يخليك تبغى
تقرا في التاريخ او تتساءل شلون البشر
بيعيشوا في
المريخ اخاف كثير اني افقد الفضول
لاستكشاف
نفسي هذا المخاوف دفعتني اني اتساءل
لعدد من الاسئله كلها تتشارك بشيء واحد
ماذا لو ماذا لو بدات السلسله هذه
بتجربه التجربه اتت قبل التساؤل اللي هي
بعد ما سلمت المفتاح لاخر منزل زكنت فيه
في طوكيو قبل 1676 يوم تحديدا اللي يحسب
ايام الفجا بوند او المسمى بالتشرد
الاختياري وقاعد افكر انه فعلا انا الحين
سلمت مفتاح اخر بيت سكنت فيه ومقبل على
مرحله جديده لا اعلم الى اين انا ذاهب
ماذا لو فعلا فقد نعمه الماوى مثل ما
فقدوها ناس كثير بدون اختيارهم ماذا لو
وهذا طبعا السؤال جر معه اسئله ثانيه وهذا
كانت صوره اخر بيت اللي هناك ماذا
لو فقدت مثلا القدره على استخدام وسائل
المواصلات اللي حولنا او ما توفرت وسائل
المواصلات حولي ماذا لو فقدت القدره على
الكلام ماذا
لو لم تتوفر لي وسائل استخراج الماء مثلا
او الوسائل ومصادر اللي ناخذ فيها الماء
والكهرباء هذه كلها
تساؤلات قررت اني احولها الى تجارب
وجربتها بعض الاحيان بنفسي او بالحالي
وبعض الاحيان مع اصدقاء لي نخوض التجارب
هذه مع بعض وكنا احنا اللي نختار قواعد
اللعبه هذه ونختار الاسئله ونضع الحدود
بناء على معرفتنا بانفسنا وبقدرات اللي
نقدر عليها انا مو هنا اتكلم عن تفاصيل
التجربه هذه او ش شفنا ش جربنا ش سوينا
ولا ابغى اقول لكم اطلعوا من بيوتكم
ارجعوا للصحراء صوموا عن الكلام لا لا
ابدا هذه كلها اشياء شخصيه بحته اللي ابغى
اترككم معاه او ابغى اوصلكم اياه اللي هو
ان نتساءل في كل يوم ماذا
لو هذا التساؤل وباعتقادي ومن تجربتي هو
الذي يشعل هذا الفضول او شعل شعله الفضول
اللي تضمر وتضمر مع السنين ومع انشغالات
الحياه نحتاج دائما كل فتره وفتره ان
نشعلها مره
اخرى انا اضمن لاي
واحد يقرر انه يتساءل وقرر انه يحول هذا
التساؤل الى تجربه
انه فيه عوائد كثيره لكن على الاقل
بختصرها في اخر اربع اشياء قد تحصل لك
واحده منهم او كلهم اولها انك ستكتشف بعدا
اخر عن نفسك ستعرف نفسك بطريقه مختلفه
تماما في في احد الرحلات الاخيره لاول مره
من 29 سنه اكتشف ش الاسباب اللي فعلا
تجعلني اغضب بشكل كبير لولا اني خرجت عن
دائره الراحه وجربت التجربه هذه لاول مره
بديت اعرف ش الاشياء اللي فعلا ترعبني
يخوفني وكنت اظن انه ما في شيء صريح مثلا
يخيفني او يرعبني في ذاك
الوقت ستدرك مدى قدرتك على التاقلم
الانسان كائن عجيب لو ت حطيته في اي ظرف
وفي اي مكان يظن انه ما يقدر يظن وانا كنت
اظن كذلك لكن سرعان ما سبحان الله يتاقلم
مباشره مع الظروف اللي يضع فيها مهما
كانت ستعي فعلا ما هو المهم في حياتك اما
الاشياء الثانيه التي تعتقد انها اساسيه
ستكتشف قدرها
فعلا واخيرا لتقدر قيمه ما تملكه
الان هذه قد تبدو للبعض انها مبتذله او
كلام فقط لكن صدقني مع
التجربه ستستشعر هذه الكلمات اللي اتكلم
عنها ابي اترككم بس بكلمه اخيره ارجوكم مع
زحمه الحياه هذه لا ننسى ان نتساءل ماذا
لو
وبس شكرا
لكم